so next talk is by car they say will be
telling us about Craig nice approach to
pseudo-random generators from
pulverizing random walks and I should
mention that some of the techniques and
in this word used by avi che and his
work that he'll be telling us about
after lunch thank you very much
so this is a joint work with you some
said to Patty and we are hi Tammy and
Shahar love it I'm going to introduce
the Durham generators quickly and
describe this new approach to construct
pseudo-random generators and then
describe some open problems just to set
up the form some basic notation let's
say we have a class of functions f that
are defined on some domain D and take
real values and you can think of these
as class of tests that are supposed to
test something and we have the totally
random object on this domain which is
just the random variable that takes
uniform values and now we have another
random variable X defined on this domain
D and then we call this X to be epsilon
pseudo-random or say X epsilon fools
this class if for every function in my
family the average of the function when
I apply to X is very close to the
average on uniform random variable but
usually the interesting cases when you
pick the domain to be the boolean cube
and I pick made this weight minus 1 1 to
the N later you will see why I draw
people dismiss this specific choice of
numbers but so we just stick with this
dummy so the goal is to construct this
random variable and by that I mean I
just need a algorithm to sample this
random variable and it has to have I
need to use few coin flips as possible
in the construction and also they are
the algorithm should be explicit
depending on whatever model you write no
way
so you can formalize this by saying you
have this function G that takes s bits
that's truly random bits and gives you n
bits that n is much larger than s and
your random variable X would be G
applied to uniform random variable on s
bits and I call this s to be a sibling
this was the basic notation so let me
just give you an example let's say we
take the class of tests to be our linear
characters of this space F 2 to the N so
that means you take all monomials there
are multi linear for every subset of one
up to n you have a multi linear monomial
and your function is just all of this
class because of all of these monomials
and X if you have a random variable X
that epsilon folds this class we call
that epsilon by smart variable so we
will use this later and this is also
there are optimal construction for this
is basically known and they take log n
over epsilon matrix ok so let me just
quickly describe some general approaches
to construct pseudo-random generators so
one idea is to take these basic
pseudo-random generators like epsilon
bias generator or chaos independence and
just combine them in a simple way to
give you PR T's for stronger classes for
example this is a result of the viola
that showed if you add a d many epsilon
biased random variables you can fool the
greedy F 2 polynomials so this is one
line of work another is based on random
restriction which is closer to the
approach that I'll be talking about this
was initiated by Italian good person and
the idea is to do the following in the
first step you have your classic
functions it's a specific function class
and then you want to show that when you
apply random risk
friction to this function class your
function class simplifies by that I mean
you pick many of the variables randomly
and assigned minus 1 1 and values to it
randomly so you have to do the step 2 is
to do randomize this statement by that I
mean you have to show the following
under pseudo random restrictions again
also the function class should simplify
and that would mean that you get a
pseudo-random generator for this
function class but one problem with this
approach is that usually even if you
were able to show this step one step two
is usually difficult and it gets really
complicated to switch random with pseudo
random here and it depends heavily on
the town the specific function class
that you choose and you absolutely could
cut it could get complicated and one of
the consequence of the current work that
I'll be describing okay so this one
things that you can for this function
class you can basically take circuits or
branching programs or more special cases
of those so one of the consequences of
the current work is that we give a
generic method to do this step two
so we don't really need to look at what
function class are we giving it's just a
more general approach that it works for
every function class satisfies one and
this is just one of the consequences
actually and it turns out that you can
do much more than this so I will
describe this later okay so but to
explain the approach I have to first
introduce an intermediate object and
which is a more relaxed version of
pseudo-random generator and that is we
called a fractional pseudo-random
generator so what was the pseudo-random
generator we had this cube this minus 1
to the n cube and you have a function
that takes values on the vertices of the
cube if you have any function of this
form you can just motive linearly extend
this function to over all of our end
right so you can get a unique multi
linear polynomial and but we're only
interested in inside the valley is
inside of this Q so we only take we look
at only minus 1 1 to the n this molecule
and it's easy to see that just because
the vertices were taking minus 1 values
the inside the cube the function will
also take values minus 1 1
there's one easy way to see is that look
at this particular line and the function
is just completely linear here and its
boundary is between minus 1 1 so it has
to be between minus 1 1 or the boundary
and you can just continue this volume
okay so so now let's go back to the
definition of pseudo-random generator
what did it mean I claim that this now I
have take the average of my function
applied to this random variable X and I
just want to compare it to the value of
the function defined at the center this
is because this was previously average
over the uniform and averages over the
uniform is just applied to the average
of uniform an average of uniform is just
the center this is because the function
is multi linear
so now we have to relax this definition
the only thing to relax about this is to
say your random variable is allowed to
take arbitrary values between minus 1 1
I called fractional PRG let's say that
could mean that your distribution could
be over these points inside the key but
there is one problem with this
relaxation and that is this I could just
take the center to be my random variable
its constant always and it's always 0
would be 0 so that would be my trio
pseudo-random generator but but we have
to say rule out this case later in order
for it to be useful
so now there are two questions about
this one is that is this relaxation
helping you in any way so can you
construct this fractional pseudo-random
generators be more easy your and can you
use this Sood around these fractional
versions to get standards to the random
generators so let me explain the second
question first so okay so not the
questions I have this random variable
that has this property but it's not -1 1
and I get want to get a random variable
X Prime on the vertices of the cube the
main idea is that you want to do a
random walk that fairly fastly it
converges to the vertices of the cube
and but I want to use my I want to use
this regular this fractional TRG and
that I'll use it to do my random walk so
I used it as steps for my random walk I
will explain why going in -
so let's first rule out the trivial PRG
so I had this random variable X that
it's on n coordinates X 1 up to X and I
don't want it to be trivial so I enforce
that on every variable typically my
random variable is not 0 so it's bounded
away from 0 typically so I have a
constant P that for every coordinate
this average of the square root of my
random variable is on the blowpipe
there's our main theorem you have a
front arbitrary function class and
variables we need this extra technical
condition that your function class has
to be closed under restriction that this
is pretty much every function class
satisfies every interesting class of
functions that is like this and you have
any fractional pseudo-random generator
so it's any distribution that satisfies
this property and it's also non-trivial
and the sense that there is a P so that
this happens then there is an X prime
then there is a function G and before
that then you can use T copies of this
fractional so the random generator so I
use T independent copies and I have a
function that I apply it to these T
copies and I get this X prime which is a
standard pseudo-random generator and if
the original error was epsilon the error
here is epsilon T and so the only thing
to say is you don't need to use too many
independent copies and the independent
copies the number would be 1 over P log
of n over epsilon where P was this lower
bound
so I'm using TNT burn copies if I
originally for the fractional PRG I had
s bits then now I just use the seed
lands would be T times us okay so let me
just describe the main idea for this
again we want to do a random walk so
let's say let's see what we have we have
this fractional PRG what does it mean it
is basically that you have the center
this is zero and it's as if I'm saying
that I'm taking one random step from the
center and typically the value of my
function doesn't change
that's what is this so if we could
continue this process if we could I know
I came here the value didn't change
typically so if I continue doing a
random walk and converse to one of the
vertices then that would be great
so I let's say I took this random step
but I want to continue this but now the
questions can airily continue can I
again take a step and say that the value
didn't change the thing is this only
talks about difference from this Center
so I cannot just directly use this but
but if I knew somehow that this new
point is center of some other queue or
some other function that still my pr's
fraction will be already works for then
I would be in good shape so what's the
natural thing to do is just look at a
sub cube that this is in the center and
so look at the largest sub here then
this is the center inside this B cube so
this is my stop cube and this is now the
center but now I have to I had my
original pseudo-random generator I have
to also scale that so I had my
distribution now I'm scaling it here I
didn't explain so I'm just now assuming
this might just PR D was just let's say
some distribution over these four points
okay so now I have this then I can wipe
so what's the question now is the
question if I can do take another step
here then the function function doesn't
change much and that is because you can
see this easily that this new function
that's defined on this sub Q is actually
in the convex hull of restrictions of
the original function that you started
with so since we know our class is
closed on the restriction and we know
that this new function is in this convex
hull and if it's in the convex or then
the PRT should also works for that
yes are the coordinates filled
differently in each dimension yes so
yeah I mean just completely
independently everything happens in
coordinate light-independent
because at the end of the day on each
coordinate I want to be very close to
minus 1 and 1 ok so let me okay so now
the question is why this would converge
fast to one of the vertices so the idea
is that continue doing this for example
that now I'm here take another step now
look at this the cube that has this to
be the center which is this one
now you take a step from here let's take
it from here and then that's so on and
continue and this whole cube as you can
speak converges to one of these vertices
if you want to say that it should happen
fast so there shouldn't be too many
steps
so the idea for the fast convergence is
that because every coordinate everything
happens independently I just need to
show this for one coordinate only and so
let's let's prove this
this is lemon dilemma today I want to
prove now I have a random walk on just
one pudding so it's on -1 1 and in the
beginning I'm at the center and I have
this random variable y sub T which is
the location at step T and how do I do
this so originally I had this fractional
PRD which with this Wrangler blonde
minus 1 1 right so I'm at step t minus 1
and I look at the largest cube that this
is the center that means that the length
of the cube would be this because this
is a distance from the boundary and I
scaled my fractional PRG step because
this was the number that could be
between minus 1 1 so I have to scale
this by this number so this whole thing
stays between minus 1 1 okay and so this
is my just this random walk that steps
get scaled as we get closer to the
boundary and the only assumption I have
is that the random variable X that I
pick independently from is also
symmetric so it's average is 0
and we want to say that the following
that if this random variable X was
typically not zero so if basically
anyway so look at this is the number of
steps that you have to take one over
average of x squared and don't only need
log of one website and you say after
this many steps with high probability
the distance from the boundary would be
less than Epsilon okay so let's just
quickly see this basically this is
basically the whole proof so it's you
can basically check case-by-case and you
get this inequality that the distance
from the boundary at step I is always
less than distance from the boundary at
step I miss I minus 1 times 1 minus X I
X I is an independent new copy of X that
I'm using so this is independent and you
can take average now the problem is this
average because this was symmetric this
average is just 1 so this is not helping
me much of it if you take the square
root of this random variable ok so what
the thing to think that's helping me
here is that average of the square root
of 1 minus X I is bounded above by
something less than 1 because you can
just write the Taylor expansion of the
square root of 1 minus X and then you
can write this down and this is using
the fact that X was symmetric because
I'm not I don't have W network so I know
I get a constant C that is this one and
I get this bound on this so what does it
mean I just write average of square root
of 1 minus of 1 minus of I is bounded by
its step I minus 1 times 1 minus C and
this is so you can see I steps this is
exponentially small
so that's basically the proof
oh and so now that we are very close to
the boundary we can just round the value
to the sign of walking
so this was how you can this was for
only one coordinates
you just Union bound over every
coordinate and get this to be close in
every coordinate and so now the question
is can we construct this fractional PR
it is easier than standard PR jeez so
there's one very general very weak
assumption about class of functions
that's about their growth of fourier co
efficients and i'll describe that and it
turns out that you get a very easy
fractional PRG for just white class of
functions that was not known for it so
so the difference for a coefficient is
this you just wear a substitute went up
to nu the average of your function the
correlation with this monomial and then
we say this function f has bounded for
growth if you look at all the for your
characters of humming like exactly K for
every K and you just add up all of those
this is bounded by some constant some
parameter C to the K so this all this so
the only thing that is important this
parameter C the better power you get was
so for example you can just always take
seed to be in
so
so how can we construct a fractional PRG
for this class so I have arbitrary class
of functions that the only thing I know
about every function in the family is
this
okay so the idea is the following you
just have pick a epsilon by his friend
variable and so again just to remind you
this was the average of for every subset
of s to the monitor and his average was
less than epsilon and I scale this
epsilon by random variable this is a
random variable R minus 1 to 1 to the
end but I don't need this I just need
some fractional PRG so I just scale this
to be something inside the cube I have
the parameter okay I have a parameter C
and I just scale this by whatever to C
where C was this thing
so now the X is taking always taken out
of the ditch me - 102 cm - see ok so
let's see why this works it's the end
very simple what is what do we want to
burn you want to bound the average of X
- 0 so this was F of 0 so it's we've
just removed it trivial for a
coefficient the rest is just exactly
this and you can just write down this
and yes inside and just now use the
definition of this X I this X which was
just scaling of Y so I just write down
this and now I use my assumption on the
level K so I add up all the level case
here ok we knew this is less than
Epsilon and now you add up all the level
of KS and this is 1 over 2 to the K and
this is less than Epsilon so we can have
now this fractional PRG but now this was
the scaling of this thing right
this is the scaling and it's average is
if you look at average of x squared on
every coordinate it would be like 1 over
some constant times C squared these are
the values because this takes value of 1
or 2 cm one yeah so basically you can
this is the number of steps that we have
to do to construct the original the
standard pseudo-random generator and
this is the seedlings for the for the
epsilon biased this is actually not
epsilon by the top almost k wise because
you don't really need this but not all
of the Hamming weights you can just x1
almost give I would it would be enough
so this would be the total seedlings for
your function family so the only
interesting parameter here is C so if
you just give me any function family and
you can prove a good bound on C then you
would just in a black box way would give
you this so for example this paper
proves something that a consequence of
it is that you can pick for functions of
sensitivity s you can pick C to be s
here it's something stronger but this is
all we need so if you just plug in this
it would give you Sigma s squared times
a lot and this improves this previously
sort results significantly by prion
Avishai which was 2 to the square root n
to choose the square test
another example is in this paper again
they have a bound on this Fourier
spectrum of taking C to be W squared for
branching programs of width W for the
permutation branching programs now you
can just use it directly to substitute
its you get W to the 4 times something
ordered for read most branching programs
there is this type of bound not for C
and for AC 0 surface also you can take C
to be log it into the block to the deal
side of the circuit so yeah I mean the
many sequels W squared what are the
paper give honesty what previous result
was W well this route this paper gives
you w to the for log of something plus W
to the squared log of something this one
has a better dependence this is better
dependence on log n compared to this
paper
yes this this gives gets lock squared
and this is only
so yeah but the message is that this is
really a general framework you can just
you don't need to know anything about
these classes you just need to know just
before it goes so let me just describe
some open problems questions so one way
to think about this construction is that
we had this fractional just random
variable X that was some original
pseudo-random generator and we took T
independent copies of that so this is
let's say this is all the K independent
copies and on each clock
yeah each coordinate we separately
applied this specific gadget that was
simulating this random walk specific
gadget that we were doing and at the end
we were getting a pseudo-random
generator for another for the class that
they were working with or in the work of
viola you can pick this G to be this
addition and after the one general
question is that what our type of
gadgets that really are useful here what
this is a one a random walk gadget works
addition works for polynomials and in
general what kind of gadgets are
interesting to replace with this type of
this kind of approach another thing is
that if you know something more about
the class to function class that you're
working with can you terminate your
random walk earlier because right now
what I want is that on every coordinate
I want to be very close to minus 1 or 1
I want to be epsilon over n close to
minus 1 1 can you do something
can you terminate earlier if you knew
something about
a result of this one for another
question that might be interesting is
that can you construct hitting sets with
this approach with other parameters a
few things break down and I don't know
how you how some construction here I
think said that would look like this you
like in the calculation that you did you
you start from an epsilon su the RAM
epsilon bias yeah yeah but you this
decay right it's like 1 over 2 to the C
to the 1 over K so you only care about
all three exactly so you don't need to
be really uniform over all of them
that's why I said just almost K wise
would be enough so that would just if
you use almost kr they would just give
you see lines log log n plus log 1 over
epsilon and that is just
so I like the differential just I'm not
sure I work so it was really known that
so the Groves already implies that you
know you can you can take fun advances
it's abuse right some noise or take
restrictions and pull the function and
just repeat
so once restrict it to just to keep
listening you you end up with the
functioning of constant enemies and is
42 so this is a much weaker assumption
I'm only looking at l1 norm instead of
that you need for that includes bond on
l1 norm doesn't give anything about
random restriction even take the parity
function satisfy this usual pseudo
random example so this is the way to the
randomizer switching them I know over so
it's not so clear that this axis black
box going like you need to show like a
wise restrictions also simplify your
function right if you want to repeat
this chaos why don't you just play I'm
just going to restrict the number of
beats that I'm working you know fiction
I'm just going to be on Stuart Beach
then I just apply the process there I'm
not doing any of us intimately
understand this really deep breath every
time what was the note you choose this
trick shot oh I see
[Music]
results about biased GMP models of
chatterjee that one is done which also
works like that so there's any any
commonality and you know some no
generals like what they can you
cooperate tomorrow yeah hard question I
don't know I would really like to
construct some other pseudo-random
objects with this framework maybe could
it be useful to construct I don't know
expanders or anything I mean because all
of these also you can formulate some
fractional version of those
pseudo-random objects and it's just the
general question that if you have the
suitable fractional pseudo-random object
how can you convert it to a one does
here the most important thing about this
is at the high dimensional object
they're only working with each dimension
independently but for these other things
like expanders and stuff I don't know
and in general I don't have any big
picture view of how does this fit to
other one
so let's think of a again
[Applause]